c'est parti pour gagner les bd que
stéphane plaza et sa console jude law a
noté dos reis aime beaucoup les qui
arriveront sur la table mais laisse un
mec qui me l'a fait oui ah ben c'est bon
tu peux pas longtemps tu vas me dire
pour reposer maintenant j'arrive à dire
non alors les séries on y va passez-moi
l'aval donné je remercie attention il va
maintenant il faut que dès qu'il déniche
alors oui ces tournants tatum celte on
attend mais il en est là notre côté
aussi jouer
joomla
même jour tu rejoins à maxime
guimberteau tient au maire face à cyril
[Musique]
méjane ce match en moins c'est moche
j'animais rien dit mais tu connaissais
pas je suis venu des usa mais les
méchants séjour elle a été méchante à
savoir passe la bande organisée je vous
rappelle qu'il resterait à deux il ya
quelqu'un qui vous attend
mais d'abord georges où les gens bouffe
balle était comme ça voilà
ben et la fin du match mathew tait
mathieu mais c'est incroyable tout le
monde arabe est le méchant
[Applaudissements]
attention messieurs
elle est méchante maintien isabelle
morini bosc
[Applaudissements]
c'est chaud
les chalets donc si l'inflation c'est
coup-de-poing autres basa maya tels des
mois on croit voir quelqu'un en ligne
qui va jouer avec nous a perdu ma fille
alors à la tête avec nous oui comment tu
t'appelles mon chéri ce qu'on met un peu
plus de son mecheri merci stéphane salue
ses vannes comment ça va bien ça va et
toi tu es venu pour discuter nous pour
gagner ça va tu nous appelles de mon
chéri cinemacon à côté de lyon mâcon un
côté lyon car été reconnue la ccabp and
soul connaît sa maman chérie tu fais
quoi dans la vie de déstockage ont ils
tous cas de 10 to cage de déstockage tu
as bien stéphane plaza ouais j'aime bien
derrière votre ordinateur
je kiffe diouf le 19 l'adorent j'ai eu
du pot 1
oui bah oui bonjour dangereux votre
chéri tu peux gagner quelque chose qui
commence par clé qui finit par stephen
tue pas l'air sûre qui tue paris / qui
en trois ans
[Rires]
quoi
[Musique]
j'étais pris pour mcenroe
même papa tu m'as tout répond nec
houas
l'état sans merci et bonne voiture et
lui
[Applaudissements]